hey guys Pete here did you like the
finale of mr. robot season three well
this is gonna be my mr. robot season 3
episode 10 recap and review I had mixed
feelings about it
I enjoyed it while I was watching it the
acting was great the music was good
there were some great moments involved
with the whole thing and we did get some
answers
we got a conclusion two things related
to 5/9 I guess you could say but I'm not
sure I'm happy with that part of it I
don't know I had mixed feelings I can't
tell you that it was something I loved
or something that I hated I really did
enjoy it while I was watching it but as
far as the overall series goes I'm not
really loving where we're at at the end
of the season I have read some reviews
of this episode and I've watched it a
couple times and I see that there's a
couple different major opinions about it
some people really liked it they think
mr. robots back after trailing off into
the woods in season 2 and then there's
people that are more like me who are
thinking that season 2 was awesome what
the hell are you guys talking about I
don't think it's polarizing I think you
can enjoy it and still not be exactly
happy with the story because it's
ongoing
so I would say that I enjoyed watching
I enjoyed the series I can't wait to see
more of it but I'm kind of bummed out
that we're hanging where we're hanging
and that veera is coming back so let's
recap what happened first and foremost
we got everything down to Elliott being
by himself in the last episode and we
see how that all plays out even though
Elliott was alone he is actually back
together with mr. robot and we see that
both parts of his personality are
necessary for what he has to do these
two have been not communicating
throughout the entire season and now
they are back as a team for the most
part I think this all works pretty good
because by working against Elliot mr.
robot found out for himself that
whiterose had
manipulating him all along the to
finally get together back in the ferris
wheel and it works pretty good I think
they both actors really killed this
little exchange here and there's a lot
more give-and-take and Elliott realizes
what he has to realize after he gets
filled in on what's going on they go
after Santiago but unfortunately Irving
is there to intercept them
Santiago was taking Darlene and Dom to
the farm where Tyrell spent most of his
time coordinating things whenever he was
off the radar and it ends up with Elliot
mr. robot Darlene and Dom all sitting
there waiting to be executed from what
we can tell we have urban air Leon and
grant shows up later but I think this
was probably necessary to bring all
these people together the only person
that's missing is Angela and we find out
that when she got scooped up by that van
last week it wasn't white rose it was
Phillip price again I don't think this
was so bad necessarily because how would
Angela really come back from her
psychosis or her breakdown whatever you
want to call it and figure into what
happened at the bar but even though this
was pulled off pretty well and this has
been a theory for a long time that price
was actually her father which we find
out is the case and I think that the way
that Michael Christopher acted here was
perfect because he tells her this stuff
as a matter of facts there's no emotion
and that's exactly how you would expect
his character to be the part that comes
up a little bit short here for me is
what exactly does this all mean I mean
yeah she had to find out what she found
out from him he was the only one in the
position to give her that information
that everything that she believed all
this stuff she did I mean she was
complicit and killing a lot of people
there all of that was over nothing it
didn't have a purpose it was a little
thing that White Rose was stuck on and
we saw that she just wanted to slap
Phillip prices hand
and things like casualties don't seem to
bother her much but price does seem
sincere in his detached way of dealing
with people you know he kind of get that
from his description of how he treated
Angela's mother and how that all played
out
and so he's invested in what happens to
her we've seen that already we didn't
know exactly that that's why but where
does it go from here like this Phillip
price now become a good guy on the side
of Angela and Elliot that's a bit of a
stretch but we can't really tell at this
point while this is all going down of
course we're going back and forth
between what's happening at the barn and
we see a pretty fitting and impactful
little scene with Irving Tom and
Santiago which ends in Irving driving
and hacks into Santiago's chest over and
over again as he convinces Dom that she
needs to work with the dark army you
know I say it's fitting because if you
think about how Urban's character has
been he's been always cool calm and
collected and he's been doing all this
stuff and he's had to deal with real
problems and he's done it as a
professional but you kind of saw when he
says these are for me after he names off
all of Dom's family members that they'll
kill if she doesn't do what they say you
can see that earring was in a place
where he needed to unwind and I thought
the scene worked good I mean I didn't
know he was gonna go for Santiago so I
was surprised I thought it was brutal
but he was still in character and if you
were a fan of his character in Boardwalk
Empire you know this was the thing that
has always been under the surface for
Bobby Cannavale I guess it could have
been a little bit too brutal for some
people but it gets us where we need to
go and Elliott has to do what he has
always done best and that is manipulate
the situation we see that he's not only
been doing what he's been doing as far
as trying to figure out how to own their
network but he's also figured out a way
to help White Rose in a way that Grant
never could do like I said I like the
way the displayed out I like the going
back and forth the music was really good
grants when he showed up that was a
really cool little montage
and in the end what Elliott has is
enough we see white roses watching the
whole time and she sends Leon a message
he kills the other guys from the dark
army that are there and then grant gets
the bad news that he won't be involved
with the plan going forward and even
though she doesn't tell him that I feel
like he was pretty much expected to kill
himself there there's not wasn't some
random thing that just happened like we
saw that before whenever the dark army
people were gonna be caught they killed
themselves and if we think about white
roses idea but especially framed in what
Phillip price told Angela White Rose
saying that I'll come and find you when
this is all over doesn't really like in
white roses mind doesn't matter if he
dies here or not I guess I mean we're
gonna have to figure out more about that
in the coming season
but according to price it's a delusional
thing that white rose wants to do and
that's where all this pain and suffering
comes from so somehow or other Elliot
devised a plan to move the plant to
Congo he gets out everybody that he has
left is still there of course Tyrell is
a puppet DOM is a puppet Darlene who
knows what she's got left at this point
and it really boils down to Elliot mr.
robot now it did not end there Elliot is
able to recover the encryption keys he
finds out after dawn let's summon
Sentinel that it wasn't Romero that
copied the keys it was that Romero was
snooping and that mr. robot had done
that the information they needed was
always in Elliot's apartment from the
get-go we find out the answer to a
season's long mystery about Elliot being
pushed out of his window that never
actually happened he jumped
I believe Darlene and her version of
events after he gets that information he
waits for mr. robot on the train and
they talk and mr. robot says he wants to
be a team and Elliot sees a glimmer of
hope in that those people showed
themselves that 1% of the
percent that he talked about in the
beginning of the first episode sure by
reversing five nine all the money and
the power goes back to II Corp and
they'll probably be up to their old
tricks in no time he still sees that
this is a step forward and I don't know
that I felt like an end to me an end to
a season they reversed everything and II
Corps without Philip price at the helm
is just as powerful as they ever were
the rich get richer the poor are still
screwed Elliott had a lot of people that
he cared about died in this process and
I was really hyped up to see what the
end of the season you know that after
credit scene was because we've been used
to that in this mr. robot saga and I was
hyped all the way up until I saw that it
was Berra Fernando mara if you watch my
own recaps and reviews you know I wasn't
a big fan of his character he didn't
seem to do a whole lot except for exists
to kill Elliott's girlfriend that we all
liked I didn't find him particularly
interesting um yeah so he is the teaser
for the next season and what does his
coming back have in store for us that's
gonna make things so much better so yeah
I guess it just really comes down to
what you think about that are you happy
I mean do you see that this is a path
back towards the revolution of season
one do you think this is Sam s male and
his writing staff saying look we we
really like what we did in season two
but the critics didn't like it the fans
didn't seem to stick with us we need to
go back to what this shows about and if
that's the case how do we get to mr.
robot and Elliot being a team to do what
they did again just after undoing
everything they did the first time so
yeah I just feel a little bit like I
have faith in the show I have faith in
the writers I think Sam s smells great
so I'm not worried I'm not upset I'm
just a little bit in the dark about
where this goes I mean we have DOM is a
great character
and she is firmly in the middle of
things that's a good thing Phillip price
is sort of in limbo we know what right
white rose is all about I mean obviously
we want to learn more about what's going
on at Washington Township in the Chinese
Republic of Congo but yeah I'll be
interested to see what you guys think
because I just don't really see where we
go from here as of yet at the end of the
day or the end of the season as it is
here Eliot is at least satisfied that he
was able to undo what he did and I think
it's not lightly hinted at there that
he's not done he still wants to go after
that 1% of the 1% is Dom gonna work for
the dark army she has to right so what
is that gonna look like did ring
actually leave for good is he really on
sabbatical writing his book I hope he
wasn't a one-off character although he
can always come back later sort of like
Fernando Vera did we'll just have to
wait and see I think Leon I hope we see
more of him he's been really he's been a
character that the writing for his
character has been really good hard to
figure out where Darlene will go hard to
figure out where Angela will go so I
guess if you're someone who likes things
to be completely up in the air then you
might be pretty happy make sure you guys
tell me what you think in the comments I
will do another like season 3 video at
some point here where we talk about what
we think might happen speculation all of
that sort of thing but for now that's
the end of season 3 mr. robot it was a
good season I was excited to watch every
episode and I was rarely let down so
gotta love that please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel and make sure that you turn on
notifications if you want to see more
videos like this if you have ideas for
shows and things like that you can come
join us on patreon and let me know what
you're interested in sort of in between
shows now so I'll be doing that over the
next week time to figure out what we can
do that's it for now guys thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon